warum geht man überhaupt noch ins museum
um kunst zu schauen das kann man doch
genauso gut im internet oder um sich zu
zeigen
um einem spektakel beizuwohnen geht es
nach ihnen christ & gantenbein steht
allein das wesentliche im vordergrund
ist das gebäude hat costa ricas es geht
um kunst und einigung nicht anders ich
glaube schon dass in einer welt wo die
virtuelle realität immer stärker wird
natürlich kunstmuseum was exponat ins
zentrum stellt kontemplation möglich ist
das jetzt vielleicht extrem altmodisch
wenn ich das so sagen aber ich glaube
das ist gerade für die junge generation
erfahren sind chancen
ob die jugend die andächtige ruhe
genießen wird in diesem gedämpften edlem
grau mit weich geschwungene marmor aus
carrara ein luxusbau ist hier entstanden
schnörkel frei mit hochwertigen
materialien und einem einsprengsel
industrie chic das belebende bunte soll
die kunst liefern
in großen räumen groß genug auch für die
höhepunkte amerikanische kunst der 50er
bis 90er jahre
perfekte bedingungen hätten sie gehabt
schwärmen die architekten ein
großzügiges budget von 100 millionen
franken breite öffentliche zustimmung
und ein fast idealtypische altbau als
ausgangspunkt unabhängig von der
organisation der hof das treppenhaus die
verschiedenen stellen
die situation unglaublich schönes
gebäude
und so findet man altes im neuen die
treppenhalle lichtdurchflutet das
seitenlicht im ersten geschoss decken
oberlicht im zweiten oder auch das
auffällige handgemachte eichenparkett
glaubwürdig soll sie sein
diese architektur keine abstrakte
gesichtslose hülle hochwertiger kratz
putzzeug von aufwendiger arbeit die
massive betondecke zeigt dass sie viel
trägt und piktogramme weisen dezent aber
deutlich sichtbar den weg museumsbau ist
mittlerweile einer ihrer kernkompetenzen
in köln bauen christ & gantenbein neuen
raum für das wallraf richartz museum und
in zürich wird ebenfalls dieses jahr ihr
erweiterungsbau des landesmuseums
eröffnet immer wieder drehte sich um das
ensemble von alt und neu abgestimmt auf
den städtebaulichen kontext auch in
basel kommunizierte neubau mit seiner
historischen umgebung hier am kopf der
wettsteinbrücke vis á vis vom alt war
und die raffinierte in beton
eingearbeitete led schrift heißt den
besucher willkommen
von drinnen schaut man wenn man abstand
von der kunst sucht durch die großen
fenster auf die geschäftige stadt ein
café gibt es nicht keine sitzgelegenheit
dass man auf den geschliffenen treffen
rumlümmeln unwahrscheinlich hier ist
alles kontemplation und kunst
verschieden
das museum ist er oft vor erhöhter
aufmerksamkeit und indem sie ist zukunft
vom museum ist die fokussierung an das
klar beweglich und architektonisch heißt
das natürlich schon eine gewisse
konzentration noch immer in die zukunft
schon letztlich in der konzentration auf
der inhalt das ist sehr allgemein aber
ich habe sich als museum maria findet
eine ausgefeilte hülle für touren
kunstgenuss die hoffentlich eine junge
generation wieder ins museum locken kann